in the opening scene we are introduced
to a Kung Fu Master named ju Yuan who
brings a new student named Chino to The
Shaolin Temple he introduces the boy to
another student Jun ba and instructs him
to brief him about the Temple's code of
conduct after the master departs Jun ba
initially addresses Chino as a junior
however Chino who is taller and older
than him insists on being referred to as
a senior afterwards junb and shinbo are
seen sweeping the floor when they hear a
group of students practicing kung fu
techniques the two of them peep through
the door and shinbo expresses that he
could outperform them if given the
chance just then a senior student
approaches and instructs them to get
back to their chores when the two boys
inquire about his identity the latter
starts bullying them asserting that he
holds Authority as their senior and can
hit them anytime he wants truly what
martial arts are all about Furious by
this mistreatment Jun ba and Chino
decide to complain to their Master ju
Yuan but to their surprise they find
that their Master is meditating under
the scorching Sun seeing this junbao
plugs off a plant to cast some Shadow on
his master but juyuan imparts the lesson
that everything has a life and that they
shouldn't harm nature for personal gain
after this the two boys expressed their
desire to learn Kung Fu as a means of
self-defense against the bullies their
Master agrees but tells them to only use
it to help others and also to leave him
alone for now so that he can finish
getting a third degree burn on his dong
later on the mischievous Duo located the
same bully encases him in a cloth and
beats him up as their Revenge however
the senior student is able to recognize
them due to which they are subjected to
a punishment by the Headmaster the two
are made to kneel in the sun without any
food for the entire day dong Burns
abound a short while later juyuan comes
to them and berates them for their
action he pretends to punish them in
front of the Headmaster but discreetly
provides them with some food following
this the two boys are assigned with the
task of cleaning the luoh Han Hall
amidst their work they also practice
Kung Fu using their brooms as the years
go by the two boys group up together to
become best friends both of them are
very determined to master their Kung Fu
moves their training includes breaking
stone piles with their heads mastering
head STS and practicing iron Palm
techniques and so on then one day they
receive news that their upcoming
promotion exam will be held soon the
scene then fast forwards to the day of
the exam where the Headmaster announces
that only the top four students will
advance to The Dore hall for further
study of superior martial arts
techniques the first round features a
duel between Chino and another student
shinbo easily wins The Duel but he is
disqualified due to his excessively
aggressive intent this obviously upsets
the boy and he ends up insulting the
Headmaster in front of everyone in
response the ladder begins fighting him
in order to teach him a lesson Jun ba
attempts to intervene but he is thrown
away during the battle the Headmaster is
astonished to discover that chin ba
knows the technique of the Buddhist
Palms hence He commands the remaining
students to form the luohan pole let's
see him Palm that pole now it is our two
Heroes versus several students in a
totally unfair battle but they still
manag to fend off their attackers after
a while Jan finally arrives at the scene
and brings the battle to a halt allowing
his two disciples to make their escape
this further infuriates the Headmaster
so he accuses juyuan of taking his
students side afterwards the two boys
meet with their Master to offer their
apologies ever juyuan informs them that
he can no longer serve as their master
and they cannot remain at The Shaolin
Temple anymore before departing he
claims that he has no concerns about Jun
BAU but shinbo has a competitive
personality so he hands Chino a book
that can help him in finding inner peace
it's called Playboy with this junb and
shinbo Venture into the outside world
seeking their paths in life in the next
scene we see them wandering aimlessly
through the streets since they haven't
eaten anything for days they approach
random people for food but nobody helps
them a short while later they come
across a group of menacing henchmen who
are harassing an elderly shop owner for
money the old man refuses because he's
already burdened by Financial woses
despite this the thugs don't listen and
begin assaulting him before taking the
money forcibly at this moment a lady
named Miss Lee shows up who cleverly
steals the money and returns it to the
elderly man when the criminals realize
the money is missing their leader
promptly orders his henchmen to beat her
up a brawl ensues and to everyone's
surprise Lee seems to have good martial
arts skills she initially takes down a
few men but is quickly outnumbered by
the rest of the group Jun ba and Chin
boo who are witnessing all of this from
a distance finally decide to help her
out with their impressive Kung Fu moves
they fight the thugs impressing the
bystanders but when they noticed the
additional reinforcements arriving the
trio opts to flee the scene they quickly
disguised themselves with fake wigs and
altered clothing allowing them to escape
later as the three are walking through
the bustling streets the people suddenly
start clearing the way it turns out that
the governor Liu Jinn is passing by the
town seeing this procession shinbo
expresses a desire to be as rich and
Powerful as the governor however Miss
Lee warns him that the governor has the
heart of a viper as he has taken the
lives of numerous people after this Miss
Lee leads the two brothers to a
restaurant for a meal while they eat
they are captivated by the melodious
music played by a woman named C Len it
turns out that cin has been searching
for her husband who has been missing for
days with nobody to support her she
sustains herself by playing the sanction
I don't know what that is meanwhile it's
clear that shinbo is developing feelings
for misley as he can't help but gaze at
her I think Chino is confusing feelings
with a half chub shortly after Leo Jin's
sister enters the restaurant with her
new boyfriend who actually turns out to
be C Lin's missing husband this
Revelation enrages cin prompting her to
get into a brawl with the governor's
sister after a long battle she gains the
upper hand but her husband who is is
eager to please his wealthy new wife
strikes culin on the head with a stool
this prompts Jun ba to step in he takes
on some of the governor's sister's
bodyguards before making their escape
with his group following this the four
of them arrive at a hotel where they
decide to spend the night at midnight
junbao and shinbo notice a group of
rebels who have stolen 300 Tales of gold
from Leo Jin the next day the two come
up with an idea to make money they
announc to the town's folk that anyone
can punch them for Ascend they also
promis to return 3 cents if they cry out
in pain in response a man and his boys
give them over a 100 cents and start
beating them up those kids will grow up
to be however they endure the
beatings without flinching a short while
later the governor's second in command
approaches the duo demanding a portion
of their earnings as taxes Jun ba
initially objects but when the commander
threatens them shinbo reluctantly hands
over the money he then makes a fool out
of himself to impress the commander
surprisingly the plan works and the
commander asks him to to join the Royal
unic where Leo Jin is recruiting new
members Chino readily agrees but junbao
is a bit hesitant at last he decides
against it resulting in the separation
of the two best friends in the days that
follow junb starts living in the
restaurant with Miss Lee Su Lyn and some
other Rebels some days later Liu Jin's
goons show up at the restaurant to
collect illegal taxes which seems to
have increased due to the governor's
greedy nature however Jun ba and the
rebels refuse to pay this infuriates the
goons who then launch an attack on them
a fierce battle ensues but jun's group
overpowers the asants one by one despite
this one of the men manages to escape to
alert Leu Jen junbao attempts to chase
him on a horse but his inexperience with
riding causes him to struggle just then
Chino who is now a soldier at the Royal
Army arrives at the scene and kills the
escaping man the two friends then
reunite and exchange stories about their
Divergent Lifestyles before departing
Chino warns junb to stay clear of the
rebels as they might get him into
trouble trouble the scene then cuts to a
competition that is being hosted at the
Royal Barracks it's revealed that the
one displaying the most exceptional
Marshall prowess will be chosen as the
general the contest begins and a
talented guy consistently defeats all
the soldiers put before him he then
challenges anyone to a duel Chino grabs
this opportunity and steps in for the
fight to everyone's surprise he easily
defeats his opponent and continues to
take down the other Challengers
eventually the competition comes to an
end but it is disclosed that shinbo has
P passed his rank leading to his
disqualification as a soldier on the
following day Chino shows up at the
restaurant with some shocking news he
informs Jun ba and the rebels that Liu
Jin has discovered the killings and has
dispatched troops to apprehend them this
worries the group prompting them to pack
their belongings and immediately vacate
the restaurant however the restaurant
owner is not so lucky as he is caught
and mercilessly killed by Leo Jen later
on shinbo junbao and their companions
resolved to assassinate eug Jin in an
effort to put an end to the ongoing
conflict shinbo points out that the
majority of the soldiers will be away
for training in a couple of days making
it an opportune moment to carry out
their assassination plan two days later
Jun B and Su Lynn assemble the local
Rebels and proceed to Leu Jin's Barracks
they discreetly make their way to
records only to be surrounded by
soldiers here it's revealed that shinbo
has set up a trap against the rebels as
well as his best friend showing his
loyalty towards Liu Jin soon hundred
hundreds of soldiers launch an assault
the rebels try their best to fight them
back but the soldiers kill them one
after another in the midst of this
commotion jinbo takes Miss Lee to his
study as he wants her as his partner
meanwhile after a lengthy and brutal
fight junbo somehow manages to escape
the barracks with the other three rebels
in the aftermath Chino's loyalty
impresses Leo Jen so he promotes him to
the position of embroidered uniform
guard Lieutenant yeah I just made that
up on the spot how do you like it
he then orders Chino to persuade Juna to
work for them or else eliminate him if
he refuses later that day Chino
approaches misslee and starts forcing
himself hon her just then leuin enters
the scene and asserts that a soldier
shouldn't jeopardize his career for the
sake of a woman also a soldier shouldn't
be a fraking ass hat as a result Chino
kills missley to prove his Devotion to
the governor's words still an ass hat
though later we learned that culin has
also been held captive at the barracks
it is only a matter of hours before the
evil guys kill her as well a short while
later Juna arrives at the barracks to
rescue her as per Leo Jin's orders Chino
tries to convince his friend to join the
Royal barracks and become rich like him
however Juna firmly declines and
expresses his profound disappointment in
shinbo who betrayed his closest friend
for the sake of money this results in a
head-on brawl between the two former
best friends for the first few minutes
they're unable to harm each other as
both of them are equally skilled but
junb soon gains the upper hand and
manages to free seen from from captivity
the duo manages to somehow get away but
junb is injured in the process after
running for a while C Lin brings junb to
his safe house and provides him with
Medical Care the ladder's injury seems
to be so serious that he starts to
display signs of mental instability
regardless culin dedicates her day and
night in his care hopeful for his
eventual recovery in the next scene
Chino makes all of his soldiers practice
rigorous Kung Fu training he warns that
those who won't comply will be
terminated right away apart from this he
also provides Leo Jinn with a report on
the captured Rebels and huge amount of
tax revenues collected one day Jun bow
is suddenly reminded of Master ju yuan's
teachings so he starts reading the book
about inner peace ah a cold over time
his health improves within the pages of
the book he learns about the concept of
a swirling ball yeah he does that can
deflect other objects upon impact while
remaining stable he also grasps the idea
that even in Stillness there are
underlying movements the these insights
Inspire him to create a new style of
martial arts that uses soft movements to
counterbalance power speed and strength
in the meantime shinbo interrogates
villagers about jun's whereabouts and
resorts to killing everyone who refuses
to divulge the information upon learning
this Jun and C Lin make a bold decision
to confront Leu Jin and permanently and
his tyrannical rule we then cut to Leu
Jin walking through the streets with his
sister accompanied by several soldiers
suddenly junb and culin appeared out of
nowhere intercepting the Convoy after
this culin engages in an intense
one-on-one combat with the emperor while
junbao confronts Leo Jin's sister and
her bodyguards the battle is deadly and
both sides showcase exceptional Marshall
skills but in the end the good guys
emerge Victorious following this junbo
and culin capture the governor as a
hostage they then proceed to the army
camp in order to confront shinbo seeing
this the soldiers attempt to intervene
but our heroes hold their swords to Leu
Jin's neck compelling them to back off
soon after chin bro approaches them and
engages in some trash talk he then
begins to clash with junbao thinking
that he is still the superior fighter
however Juna is now fighting using an
unseen style which he calls Tai Chi he
is able to fend off all the attacks with
ease as Chino nears defeat he orders his
soldiers to attack Jun ba however Liu
Jin who is still held by su Lyn forbids
them from intervening this angers Chino
so much that he kills the governor in
order to gain in complete control over
the troops surrounding them but to his
shock they still refused to obey him as
he just betrayed their leader the troops
then Stand Down leaving Chino's fate in
jun's hands now with nowhere to go Chino
pleads for Mercy But junb ultimately
finishes him off bringing all of this to
an end in the final scene Juna and cin
part ways and our hero returns Chino's
Ashes to The Shaolin Temple the movie
ends as he establishes his own School in
the wuang mountains and begins training
as a taiichi master subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching